投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,現在是臺北時間,2026年8月21號禮拜五,早上8點31分。
大家早安,我是林浩,每天早上開幕前半小時,我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經,新聞時事變化。
沒有股市這一次變成三大指數收回,結果非凡又漲回來了,所以這一輪沒有股市仍然在高位持續盤選。
不過美國財政部貝森特這一次擴大債券的回購
看起來一天行情
仍然能夠成功的去壓低長天旗的美債殖利率
昨天又漲回去了
結果才一天
發現是誤會一場
道瓊指數是下跌了700點
但費辦卻驚險收紅了0.53%
那我們這個時候就要回過頭來看
長天旗公債目前所拋售的情況為何
會不會導致貝森特必須採取更進一步的刺激政策
為什麼這樣講
因為被申責從昨天的放話
它是在9月份才要實施動作的
所以昨天的放話更像是一種前瞻之影
我準備要來接美債了
好那你告訴我
現在僅僅只有一天行情
美債重新回到上行軌道
那如果再往上破高
那是否意味著要採取更為激烈的購債政策呢
這一次財政博士宣佈
把10年到30年期
公債的回購規模從20億美元
至少提高一倍到40億美元
那市場很明顯現在不買單嘛
只拉下來一根
現在馬上又漲回去了
30年前美債殖利率
現在大概在5.24%左右
這幾乎回吐了政策公佈之後的跌幅
也明顯高於6月底4.9%的水準
那美元也是同步受到沉壓
美元指數在政策公佈當天是下跌0.8%
隔天盤中再跌最多0.3%
不管怎麼說都可以看得出來
市場真正擔心的
也不是短期流動性一定會出問題
是美國的財政結構
讓大家開始有所擔憂
因為投資整體債
把美債的真實買盤都給搶光了
那現在到底誰願意持有美國政府公債呢
因此數十億美元的規模回購
相對於以前的QE
那都是數千億美元
甚至是數兆
資產負債表整個翻倍
幾十億
錢頭不夠
有一點感覺好像在互相博弈的感覺
市場上正在逼連準會做更多的表態
買更多吧
做更寬鬆吧
那其實更大的壓力
當然來自於美國的國債中
美國國債這一次在本月份
已經正式突破了40兆美元
那加上現在聯邦政府財政赤字
長期維持在GDP6%的高水準
你要知道美國經濟成長
這個市場上
現在二季度1.8而已嘛
我們假設樂觀一點
就按照貝森特所說的
可以來到3%
哇那3%的經濟成長
結果你聯邦政府赤字佔GDP比值是6%
那等同於昨天我們提到的
那不是花了一整年賺到的錢
那都拿去付利息了
那就是那好賭的爸生病的媽
上學弟弟和破碎的他
那酒店小姐賺的錢根本就不夠
以為自己很辛苦
發現只能繳利息一樣
那這樣的一個效果
加上國防支出也減少
國防支出在川普本任任期創下歷史新高
所以貝森特過去認為說
赤字可能已經見頂
那未來我們可以靠關稅收入
或者靠打擊詐欺收入
增加政府的收入
很明顯在短期內是沒有效的
美國國債仍然以非常驚人的速度上行
那到底這個國債
以前還想說可以借新還舊
再撐一陣子
現在連投資等級債科技巨頭
都把你的買盤都給搶光了
該怎麼處理呢
只有一種方式
財政部擴大購債的回購力度
事實上如果我們仔細觀察
現在在惡性循環的過程當中
美國大概是花多久時間
花200年才來到
第一個1兆美元的債務
那花95天
最近只花95天
可能不到100天
就增加1兆了
過去5年
本來2020年只有30兆
現在已經40兆了
所以它是不只是增速越來越快
而且那個體量越來越大
那財政部現在
之前購買10年到30年常債
那由於買的量不夠大
所以大家會覺得
如果你不是以千億級別來做觀察的話
能夠有效的去把這些買盤給吸收
那其實我沒什麼必要
認為公債殖利率就會因此而向下
頂多你稍微拖住一下
那這就是惡性循環
就是債務越高
投資人通常就會要求越高的殖利率
風險貼水
那殖利率越高
那政府的利息支出就會來得更加沉重
那利息越重
那我就要發更多的債
那現在利息已經成為美國預算的第三大項
已經超過醫療支出
已經超過國防支出了
等於是說你繳的利息
比一整年的國防支出
和醫療支出來得多
現在就僅次於社會安全
還有其他的主要福利
可能快要追上涉案支出了
那更麻煩的事情是
這些預測都還是假設
沒有更進一步衰退
沒有更進一步金融危機
如果再爆發金融危機
再一次08年
我們也知道後果是什麼
08年以後
那就是再一次的海量貨幣寬鬆
再一次的債務膨脹
所以當然
你說未來有沒有可能採取金融壓制
就是那解決債務問題唯一的方式就是高通膨
史詩級大通膨
把債務一筆勾銷
有這樣的感覺
你只要債務通膨完全失控
那債務就不值錢了
這是另外一種角度
但受慘的受到最大沖擊的當然就是中產的
那當然了
那有沒有可能是美元會先付出一些代價呢
因為美國財政部現在很明顯
想要透過買回償債來壓住長端的殖利率
那市場壓力也不會憑空消失
只是可能會從債券市場
移轉到匯市
假設他接下來還是講了很多話
來成功一支柱再施的跌幅的話
那美元市場就會有壓力了
為什麼這樣講
投資人現在因為要求更高的風險貼水
如果美債價格不能夠充分的下跌
因為財政部的介入
然後殖利率不能夠自由的上升
那對於海外投資人
比如說對我們來講
那要怎麼樣來反映這種更高的風險溢價呢
來反映出我們持有美債
我們必須要有更高的風險貼水
要給我更多的報酬呢
那可能就會透過類似美元貶值來完成
這個德銀他把它稱之為軟性金融壓抑
就類似過去扭轉操作來壓低長端利率
結果對於美元偏負面
為什麼這樣講
很好理解
因為美國可以買回自己的債
但他不能夠買回市場對於美元的信任
如果長端殖利率被政策給壓住
美元資產的利差吸引力就會下滑
那資金就可能轉向黃金
變成流向瑞郎
流向歐元
流向日元
留下亞洲貨幣
那最後就要反映在美元資產身上
所以市場總會找出路
接下來我們會從
美債和美元兩個角度
持續來做觀察
但可以確認的事情是
市場上很明顯
並不是相信現在就要違約了
現在就要流動性風險了
也沒有那麼緊急
但是所有投資人
都在對美國政府大喊
給我更多風險補償
你那一點子利率
人家Meta都給我7% 8%
人家Google都給我7% 8%
你那個30年期才給我5%
會不會太低呢
現在要求更多的風險補償
我最近才看到那個
臺灣高速公路不是有起意外嗎
那真的很嚴重
站在那個內線道
就是讓我想到以前一個案例
就是很多人會講說
那個高速公路通常是越來越安全
那有時候反而會變得越來越危險
就是當汽車一開始加入安全帶
然後加入ACC ABS防抗系統以後
再來講那個事故風險
應該會一路的下滑
但之前有經濟學家就研究
人一旦覺得自己安全
有時候就開得更快
然後就ACC
然後跟車就跟得更近
甚至更敢冒險
那不是說安全設備沒有用
它是提醒我們
人不是固定不動的實驗參數
人會根據規則改變自己的行為
這放到金融市場就特別有意思
央行每一次都救
市場每一次大跌都有流動性的支撐
原本你都覺得
財政部出手稍微降低一下風險
稍微壓低一下流動性的壓力
那久了會怎麼樣
會讓大家更敢上槓杆
因為知道有人在背後支撐
那被深測就要好好處理
這個心態的變化
大家其實都知道
不太可能會出事
而且甚至讓你跌更多
逼你出手賣更多
這是現在的真實狀況
這叫風險補償
風險似乎只是轉到
另外一端而已
安全網最大的副作用
就是有人把它拿成
當成彈簧床
一個制度讓人覺得不會死
那人就會往往
做以前不敢做的事情
跟車就跟得更近了
然後標就標的更快了
甚至就是沒有主動開車
就手放著閉上眼睛
很多人現在開車也是這樣的
因為自動跟車
那不管怎麼說
市場上現在更進一步關注的
就是美國股市的反應
其實更多感覺像是博弈
是在逼你買更多
而不是讓股市開始往下跌
我們舉例來說
道瓊也沒跌多少
跌700.1.32%
摔52759點
這一波本來就創高了
稍微回檔而已
標普下跌66.0.87%
收在7,641點
納指下跌263點
1%
收在26,067點
反而費辦還上漲
上漲61點
0.53%
收在11,800點左右
當然市場上
現在更進一步觀察的
是投資人
華爾街跟財政部的博弈
已經正式開始
第二層博弈
是白宮跟科技巨頭的博弈
也正式開始了
我們知道美國的
政治和財富的結合
已經進入了新階段
這一輪中期選舉
最大的特色就是
以前都是石油巨頭
醫療巨頭
這些巨頭在中期選舉
各自幫助自己的候選人
那以前會覺得
可能醫療股比較偏民主黨
然後加密貨幣
可能比較偏共和黨
但這一次可以確定的事情是
大量的AI圈雙邊壓住
這一次AI巨頭
對於本輪期中選舉
是一個新的產業鏈資金的流落變化
川普內閣成員合計
身價大概是75億美元
都是在過去兩年大幅暴增的
那當然現在民主黨
也獲得了同樣的一個資金
這說明未來不論是其中選舉結果為何
其實巨頭們對於接下來白宮政策
或者對於參議院的影響來得越來越大
那當然很多巨頭
也會因此而形成民意上的壓力
我們要知道你在美國走一圈
你會發現美國反對AI的人
感覺從實質感受體感溫度來看
從民調展現來看
看起來是比對於AI抱持樂觀的人
還要多非常非常多
這是至少從民調呈現展現的
所以它就變成兩種平衡
這政治人物就必須要在
AI巨頭的政治現金的幫助
和選民對於AI所造成的擔憂當中
取得適度平衡
像Anthropic他就以身作則
這次創辦人身價640億美元
他向金融時報表明
現在有60多名的現任和前員工
承諾至少捐出10%的收入
給大眾
他也承諾
未來他會捐出80%的個人財富
來回饋社會
這叫做有效利他主義
不要覺得AI永遠都是在賺大家的錢
我們一定會想辦法去回饋社會的
這是一種角度
但另外一方面
右派本身也在內戰
就是我們到底要的是科技霸權
還是我們要的是更多的金融權利
科技權利
我們舉例來說
以前過去保守派經常會喊
支持警察
政府不要管我
這兩邊可以同時喊
一方面要求強化治安
一方面反對這些科技巨頭
政府監控或者權力擴張
但到AI時代的時候
這兩套的價值就開始正式衝突
你像Pantheon
它就是提供軍方大量的資料分析能力
然後你像Flox Safety
它是利用車牌的辨識攝影機
來幫助警方來追蹤車輛
再加上全美快速擴張的AI資料中心
支持者都認為
這是美國維持科技軍事和治安優勢
不可缺少的基礎建設
可是另外一方面反對者反的是什麼
反的是AI
AI追蹤
AI攝影機
政府資料庫
演算法結合
這右派是不希望你干預我的私生活過多的
所以真正的爭論就變成
不是說AI好不好
是你願意拿多少的隱私去交換安全和國力
中期選舉現在也是一個重要的議題
在討論這個
支持者認為
我們既然要支持警察去打擊犯罪
那就不該反對警方使用更有效率的科技
你像中國現在大體的發展AI
一下人就抓到了
美國如果因為隱私疑慮自我設限
你不止輸掉科技競賽
而且有可能治安也不是特別好
當然自由意志派
他也是右派
他認為今天你相信的政府
拿這些工具來抓罪犯
誰知道明天如果政府換人
如果左派回來的
他會不會拿同一套工具來監控你
我們之所以希望政府放鬆監管的最大目的
就是不希望他才成功的獲取這個工具
如果在我們自己手上
我們把工具給拿回來
那不是另外一種壓力嗎
這是AI時代的政治悖論
科技本身沒有左右派
但是當科技讓政府看得更清楚
記得更久
算得更快
那一邊右派就是相信
強國家小政府的人
他就要開始擔憂了
你到底是更害怕犯罪
還是更害怕政府
這就是目前細股討論
比較有趣的問題
也是中期選舉選戰的一個主軸
可是至少可以承認
現在系股巨頭
真的算是走回到了帝國時代了
在過去20年週期當中
他們也沒有如此大的權力股
第一個叫取得非自身原有的資源
他大量的使用
未經授權的個人隱私數據
以及作家 新聞記者
藝術家的智慧財產
集合成他的AI
而且都沒付什麼錢
因為他在網絡上收集資料
第二個是勞動力的高度依賴和重組
展現現在對於底層
標註勞工的低成本利用
以及對於企業內部
一般白領的自動化和替代
第三就是知識生產
和資訊出口的集中化
以後如果大量的文章
大量的發表
都是由AI來發表
其實聊天機器人
會成為取得日常資訊的單一入口
你巨頭就可以決定
你想要輸出什麼樣類型的內容
偏左派 偏右派
偏保守 偏價值
你要輸出什麼樣的內容和風格
最後就是以進步和道德論述
作為發展基礎
當然社會不斷在進步
科技不斷在進步
但是後面剛才我們提到的一些道德論述
還是有極大的壓力了
從民調層面就看得出來
事實上我們看到
在蓋洛普的民調當中
現在美國有45%的民眾
是反對再度興建新的資料中心
支持者已經掉到16%
所以如果要反映民意
他基本上就要暫時放緩一下
建制的步調
以獲取更多選票
可是AI巨頭
現在對於美國政客的遊說金額
已經遠遠超過傳統巨頭
或者加密貨幣
這就使得政治人物也是相當的糾結
如果資料中心要蓋在住家16公里內
反對比例已經升高到59%
支持者只剩下10%
更低了
所以民意已經完全轉化成政治壓力
而且罕見的跨過黨派
現在至少15個州已經提出
限制或者禁止資料中心再度建設的計劃
那最明顯的就紐約州
所以不管怎麼說
接下來有沒有可能資料中心的建制量
受到民意的壓力開始放緩
這是值得觀察的
可是這個是對於工作的擔憂
但是大家的使用量其實沒有減少
我們如果去看OpenAI最新所公佈的
不管是Work還是Gotex的
Gotex的每週的活躍用戶
年初大概是20萬
現在5月底已經來到500萬
那總體使用用戶已經高達1400萬左右
所以不管怎麼說
在今年的用缺GPT
來進行專業型工作的人數
正在進入到指數型的上升
那套用到AI也是如此
AI公司表面上
它都會像是一句話完成工作
可是有時候你會發現
最近好像
我最近使用缺GPT
還有前陣子使用缺媒體都是
有時候就是轉圈轉很久了
我不知道是不是我的用量已經到達了
那有時候也不是那麼的穩定
然後它會告訴你
它正在生成
其實你有沒有發現
有時候使用這些軟體
它其實有沒有轉圈圈都不重要
它等的時間都差不多久
有時候它一句一句慢慢的出現
跟一次出現
時間線我測過
其實都差不多
這有點像是
你去那個超市
我們去全聯
家樂福
有時候買牛奶雞蛋
你發現你都要走很遠才拿得到
看起來很沒有效率
但對超市來說
就是讓你要停留在那個
超市的時間更長
所以才要拖得更久
這叫摩擦性時間
就很多
不管航空公司
便宜票要你一路加購
電商結賬之前
你要買一些推薦商品
或者企業嘴上說流程要做到最順
那真正聰明的設計
他要先把你停留在這邊的時間更長
未來如果有相對應的服務
搜尋的服務
廣告的服務
才能夠推給你
OK
這是我們觀察到的實質現象
但不管怎麼說
市場上現在更進一步的壓力
就是錢的壓力
開始去擠壓到國債
那第二大層面
就是民意的壓力
造成建制中心的延後
那第三點
就是能源的問題
如果國家能源政策跟不上
那資料中心也許蓋好之後
沒有電可以做使用
也是一大壓力
你像OpenAI和Enthropic
最近估值都已經來到兆元級別
但到目前為止
對於自己的溫室氣體的排放
能源水資源的消耗
還是揭露的非常少
加州已經出手了
加州預估從11月份開始
要求年移收超過10億美元
在加州的公司
必須要自行揭露你自己的碳排放
也要了解說
你對於環境成本會大到什麼樣的規模
主動提出報告
讓我瞭解你要吃多少電
吃多少水
否則資料中心就有可能會因此而停建
那當然很多人說這就是最大問題
就是就算你好不容易
把民意的問題給搞定了
我們哪裡來短短几年
生出這麼多的電力呢
我相信這個問題
反而是科技層面可以做解決的
你發展更好的GPU
你推出H100 H200
H800 H1000
你不斷在推出產品的過程當中
它其實就是達到更有效率的去使用這些電量
這反而我不是特別擔心
以前我們講過那個馬糞危機
19世紀末的時候
倫敦紐約有個大危機
馬很多
到處都是大變
然後會有蒼蠅
有惡臭
然後又死
按照這個速度
當時大家都預估
城市很快就變成大變城市
就是被馬糞給淹沒
結果人類並沒有發明
排變更少的馬
那什麼事情的發生
導致這個碼份問題解決了呢
汽車出現了
所以這是最容易犯的錯
就我們拿今天的技術
線性推論今天的問題
你說2035年
資料中心需要用到多少電
有沒有可能以後
不需要用到這麼多電
只要效率不斷地做提升
所以我們講說
碼份專家最大的敵人
不是另外一個碼份專家
是亨利福特
也許可以藉由技術的改革
讓我們不用這麼的缺點
這是一個我認為
最直觀的觀察重點
其實蒸汽機改良之後
每做一件事情的煤更少了
照理來講英國的煤炭
消耗應該會下滑
但反而燒更多
這也是一樣的
就是說你說那以後就不缺電
以後可能用發電量還是會提高
以後使用的AI量體還是會提高
可是你要了解說
我們不能用單純的線性邏輯
來看待未來一切的變化
這給投資朋友做一些思考
當然這也說明著
整個AI對於消費終端的運用
其實還是要越來越快
會比較好
我們舉例來說
現在市場上在科技巨頭所壓住的
打字取代
是目前用量拉伸幅度最快的
我們舉例來說
你像OpenAI和Google
微軟這些科技巨頭
大型的投資AI語音技術
目的是什麼
就是大家都已經發現了
因為打字已經慢慢被取代
變成了對話
現在很多人不管是做模型
或者做指令
還是寫程式
真的都是用語音
用語音轉文字
或者語音直接來輸入到裡頭
原因很簡單
因為有時候
以前因為技術的關係
你在生成語音
你可能會有延遲的問題
有語氣
有上下文理解的問題
那你把你所有的數據
比如說你有一個問題
你想要提出
那文字是打不出來的
我好想知道
我們今天直播想講的這個主題
它好像跟AI有一點關係
可是跟川普政府又有一點關係
那如何用一個更宏觀的角度
來把它做連結呢
是這樣子嗎
還是說也可以加入一些有趣的段子
你有時候這個打字你打不出來
你只能用講話的
那AI它不缺你到底講話有沒有詞意
有沒有答意
重點是你要給它足夠多的數據
所以它就使得現在聲音模型的流量
正在快速的拉昇
那麼這也是未來在AI爆發過程當中的
一個市場主流
那當然了
另外一方面
我們也知道AI模型發展到現在
其實大家並沒有因此
讓工作的時間變短
反而是AI越用越忙
我們根據日本經濟財政白皮書
最新的公佈
AI確實能夠提升工作效率
但是未必能夠減少加班
大多數的企業在導入AI之後
相關的平均處理時間
的確縮短了16.7%
但是使用AI工作的人
他的平均工時
已經超過沒有使用AI工作的人
這說明什麼事情
就是大家AI使用上癮了
覺得我竟然有同樣的一個工具
那我就可以做更多產出
無形當中
反而拉長了自己的工作時間
其實有時候套用到AI產品
也是如此
模型實際運算
可能十幾秒
那有時候你發現
它總要是捐圈
或者告訴你它的思路
因為如果畫面完全停止
那很多時候
我們就覺得是不是當機了
那反而你只要上面寫
什麼正在搜尋資料
分析文件
整理答案
你就可以稍微接受
那比的就是
誰更會管理這種等待感
跟以前辦公室大樓
不是有些人會抱怨
因為那個電梯很慢
那很多人就研究各種方式
換馬達 怎麼增加電梯
重做控制系統
後來我忘記是澳美的案例
還是哪一個公關公司的案例
最便宜最荒謬的方法是什麼
就在電梯旁邊
就外面先裝一個鏡子
結果抱怨就大幅減少了
因為大家等待電梯的過程當中
就開始整理頭髮
那看一下自己
順便看一下身邊的人
所以很多的問題
並不是真的太慢
是覺得等待時間太長
所以迪士尼在你排隊的時候
要給你東西看
外送APP它要顯示
現在外送員已經騎到哪裡了
AI回答讓你感覺正在處理
這就是一個重要的作用
無形當中都拖長了我們的工作時間
重點是它有時候
新模型剛推出
這幾天我用那個
Cherry GP的新模型
它好像想很久
我覺得回答也沒有特別好
所以不如你就把它效率化就好了
那個誰講的
君子勿本
本利而道生
你放在AI產品上
你不要一開始只追求華麗的功能
參數規模換生成數
你把最根本的問題做好
回答是否可靠
資料是否安全
不要讓我等太久
讓我等太久
那你最好把你的思路展現清楚
讓我也可以跟著一起思考
這是最重要的
給大家多一些思考
當然了
這就說明著
AI其實並沒有真實完全取代工作
但它的確讓我們的生產力變高了
但生產的時間
並沒有讓我們因此而導致變少
事實上如果我們仔細觀察
你像這一輪
大家認為預估衝擊最大的印度或者菲律賓
其實衝擊並沒有想象中來得多
菲律賓原本是認為是
深層市AI最早衝擊的國家
因為它有客服
有資料輸入
有文字處理
外包服務
它業務非常龐大
2025年菲律賓的資訊科技
商業流程的管理產業人數
190萬人
比24年還增加4%
今年預估還在成長
說明什麼事情
就是那些第一線的客服
它其實沒有被AI給取代
它是AI的自動化開始導入到客服
讓這些客服在跟你對答的過程當中
有了AI的幫助
回答速度來得更快
所以新的工作
反而大家取決於你使用AI的熟練程度
這就是一種比較不同一樣
不同線性的思考
讓你瞭解
AI不一定會取代你的工作
但使用AI的人
你的生產力會做大幅提升
這當然也必須承認
美國人的擔憂還是有其道理的
就是隻是剛開始
那之後呢 之後就不一定了
最近我常聽到有人在討論那個驛站
臺北市選站嘛 驛站
讓我想到古代的驛站
不就是那個國家的資訊高速公路嗎
讓公文 官員 軍情能夠快速移動
你知道明朝是怎麼滅亡的嗎
就是明朝有很多人
就是他想搭便車你知道嗎
不是緊急的公務
他也用驛站的驛嘛
不該享受招待的人
他也想要取得憑證
最後地方就要養更多的馬
準備更多的糧食和能力
那明代後起
就有很多改革要準備出爐
其中一個改革是什麼
就是一定要改革這個龍原
尤其是驛站過多的跡象
所以就大幅的裁撤驛站
那最有名的失業的那個異族是誰呢
就李自成
他失業了
失業就殺到北京城
所以這一問題很嚴重
如果驛站到時候處理不好
到時候就業的衝擊還是陸續展現
那美國的反對聲音也只會越來越大
當然我沒這麼悲觀
在提款機出現以後
你會發現
其實金融業現在的從業人數
遠遠高於20年前30年前
一方面在經濟成長
一方面是1970年代
提款機剛普及的時候
很多人都認為
完蛋了
那個銀行櫃員要全面消失了
怎麼可能還會有人來存錢
領錢到銀行
結果發現ATM大幅增加的年代
銀行櫃員並沒有立刻消失
為什麼
因為ATM降低了分行的運營成本
銀行就有能力開更多的分行
更多的分行
雖然每個分行需要的櫃員變少了
但是分行數的增加
就把總就業撐起來了
一樣我們不要用線性的角度
來思考一系列看到的衝擊
OK
那當然剛才我們講了非常多
主要還是跟投資朋友在觀察
整個全美的AI發展到這樣的一個路線以後
它的線性邏輯
不應該做直接性的套用
那當然我們回過頭要往下看
現在在整個中國市場當中的成長速度有多快
剛才講到美國人從民調層面來看
的確對於AI是有一定的疑慮的
可是我們根據蓬勃的民調
你把它拿來跟中國市場來進行對比
兩者就差很多
你看中國民眾對於AI的接受度
還明顯領先全球
高達84%受訪者對於AI的產品服務感到期待
遠遠高於印度的65%
日本的46%
更是美國的38%
兩倍以上
這其實從體感溫度看得出來
你看得出來
中國市場對於AI的接受意願
的確比較高
常常用AI搞一些有的沒的
發表一些AI劇等等
感覺好像並沒有那種
極度的焦慮感
那明明中國經濟情況
也不是特別好
但是反而對於AI的焦慮感
沒有想象中來得大
那反而是美國人相對來得大
這是兩種價值觀的持續產生
我們必須承認
在過去幾個月當中
中國的AI真正最強的殺傷力
都並不是它的最強模型
是便宜到企業很難去拒絕
我們看美國的AI模型能力
跟中國的領先
現在看起來正在急速的縮小
從之前的Kimi K3 DeepSeq
千問到GLM
這些模型在寫成是推理金融
從蓬勃統計上
已經逼近於美國的高階模型
那重點是採用的速度
我們根據OpenRooter的數據顯示
中國模型使用量在6月份
是首次超越美國的模型
7月市佔率已經來到60%
中國生存是AI模型下載量是41.4
比美國的模型高5個百分點
那美國像是Doordash
或者ABMB Coinbase
都已經開始使用
部署在本地私服器的中國模型
它不會有數據
或者說隱私權的問題
因為它是用地端
但是重點是
因為開放權重
可以自行下載客製化
未來對於中國模型的需求
未來的更新
一定是越來越捆綁的
因為我的系統
就是採用你的技術為底
所以跟在後面的人
有時候我們比較晚出發
但是有沒有可能
可能藉由低價的方式
更早抵達終點
美國現在就是開在最前面的車
他必須要自己決定
下一個路口要左轉還是右轉
每一次選擇都可能開出新的道路
也有可能撞到死巷
創新者最大成本是什麼
就是不是研發本身
他要替整個世界來試錯
中國採取另外一套思維
他就是不會有一個模型真正超越你
永遠都跟在你後面
你左轉我就跟著左轉
你右轉我就跟著右轉
美國發展電動車
那我就跟進電動車
把成本壓到極低
你投入AI我也投AI
你投機器人我也投機器人
前車證明方向可行
我在集中政策資金人才
和供應鏈快速的追趕
別人先付那個探索成本
那中國負責吧
已經證明可行的路
走得更快更便宜
以前那個吉利汽車
它就完全幾乎是照抄豐田
因為我不確定
什麼樣的車款
會受市場中產喜歡
你出一個款
我就跟你出一模一樣的
小米素T也一模一樣
這不是模仿
它是一種算模仿
但是一種後發者優勢
第一名你要承擔技術失敗
需求不存在
標準的選錯
或者市場交易等風險
但是後面的人
他就可以跳過這個錯誤路線
他直接學習成熟方案
然後再利用龐大的內需市場
完整的供應鏈
持續性的壓低自己的規模
所以美國最擅長
就是從0到1
那中國就是從1做到100
然後再把價格從100做到10
然後這是他最會做的事情
所以中國市場就是這樣子
就是次等獲利
他不用每一次都猜中下一次革命
他都等著別人證明方向
再靠速度 規模和成本施下市場
就跟有時候投資
他不一定每一次買到低點
避開最危險的探索階段
趨勢確認之後
有了護城河之後重倉
也是一種方式
那領先者賺的都是
發明未來的超額報酬
追趕者他是複製未來
量產未來的確定性報酬
跟你做的一模一樣就好了
跟在你後面 緊緊貼著你
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
一模一樣其實是把最昂貴
最危險的探索階段
它直接跳過了
等方向確定之後
再用自己的資金供應鏈
和製造能力去追上你
所以有時候我們這樣講說
雖然這個是最有效的策略
不要急著證明自己都有創意
它只是做到跟你幾乎一模一樣
等到完全追上以後
再用雙超理論
先超越你
在價格上再做進一步的超越你
這個是我們觀察到的實質跡象
先抄襲後超越
當然了
你說做得一模一樣
那不就永遠無法超越他嗎
沒錯
他本來的目的
就不是在技術上超越大家獲取成本
而是在價格上的超越你
他之前不是講那兩兄弟
每一次見面
總是會互相調侃對方
那大哥突然撫摸小弟的光頭
你這光頭摸起來
真像我太太的屁股
那老弟也摸自己的光頭
對對對
的確一模一樣
所以這種模式也會有天花板
你沒辦法跟他做到一模一樣
可是問題在於
你永遠跟在他最後
你也很難決定下一條道路通往哪裡
當你不小心超越他以後
中國真正超越美國的關鍵
也不單單是把產品做得更便宜
是雙方如果剛好跑到同一個路口
平行了
那中國這個時候
你難道還要等美國打方向燈嗎
你要自己決定要左轉右轉嗎
跟隨能夠降低犯錯成本
但是製造能夠放大成功的成果
現在就是有一天你好不容易追上了
你自己也不知道該往哪裡走
所以這有點類似
那個以前鄭和下西洋
鄭和船這麼大
為什麼沒有變成
中國的東印度公司
大家有沒有想過這件事情
那有很多種角度
有一種是因為
因為他本身也算是
跟明朝皇帝有一些嫌隙
這是一種角度
另外一種角度就是
原因很複雜
但是其中一個
很值得注意的事情是
鄭和的航海工程
它是由國家資源
推動的政治工程
那國家在幫助你
那個歐洲不一樣
歐洲是大量的私人資本
貿易的利潤
國家力量
他們要錢
要賺錢回去的
這給科技投資一個很好的提醒
你能夠把東西做出來
跟能夠讓他自己賺錢活下去
是兩種不同的能力
靠中國政府的預算
你可以造出世界上最大的船
公司可以用融資
蓋出最大的AI資料中心
可是問題在於
如果國家不補貼了
那你自己能不能長大
你自己能不能決定
你要左轉還是右轉
這是未來可以觀察的幾大重點
好就04分
臺北股市下跌117點
本來還想聊一下歐洲的
不過我們就之後再聊好了
今天主要跟投資朋友觀察
在整個美國到中國
AI發展的過程當中
一方面美國內部
有科技巨頭的新一輪的角力
那在中國層面
也開始理解到
模型一旦追上以後
它就要採取新的道路了
因為的確
現在雙方貼近的速度非常之快
那重點在於
接下來不只是左轉右轉的問題
而是為自己下一個階段來做好佈局
今天每個禮拜五
我們通常都會跟投資朋友導讀一本書
今天導讀這本書非常好看
叫做《AI時代的人生勝負手》
這本書的作者就是李世石
李世石大家還記得
幾年前他輸給AlphaGo之後
真正受到衝擊的不單單是圍棋
他是人類長久以來的一種自我認知
這本書不是在告訴你怎麼下圍棋
它是在反思
如果連最需要直覺創意判斷的領域
它陸續都被機器給超越
那麼我們人類努力的意義
最終還剩下什麼呢
問題也許不是
人類還可以在哪個領域贏過AI
而是AI永遠它都可以給你更好的答案
更充分的答案
那我們有沒有能力提出更好的問題呢
機器現在算得比人快
好像讓數學人沒有意義
相機比人記得更清楚
但是它真的有讓繪畫消失嗎
汽車跑得比人快
我們為什麼還要爬馬拉松
因為人做一件事情的價值
它不會取決於你的結果是否來到最優解
是過程當中如何理解自己
建立關係
承擔選擇
所以沒有為期
基本的人也可以看這本書
這本書更多的是對於AI的反思
一個被AI真正擊敗的人
他是怎麼思考AI這件事情的
很有意思
AI時代真正最稀缺的
以前都是
你能不能有快速找到答案的能力
現在答案根本不重要
到處都可以找到答案
你能不能創造答案的能力
這很有意思
李士實以前叫做神之一手
他之所以動人
不只是因為那一步
之前成功的擊敗AlphaGo
應該講說
之前有勝有負
可是更因為
幾乎在所有人都認為
沒有機會的時候
他仍然願意走出一條
機器人跟人類未曾預期的路線
他知道AI當然這幾年越來越強
越來越可以取代圍棋
寫作 繪畫和城市設計
甚至部分的投資判斷
但人類有幾個無法外包的事情
你要愛誰
你要相信什麼
你願意承擔什麼樣的代價
你準備把有限的人生用在哪裡
這件事情是很重要的
所以這也給投資朋友做更進一步的思維
就跟我們講過的
攝影技術出現以前
繪畫的重要功能之一
就是記錄人物的真實長相
風景和歷史場景
相機都能夠更快速
更精確地做這件事情
畫家會因此而全部失業嗎
反而開始追問
如果繪畫不必再和現實一模一樣
它還能表達什麼呢
所以到後來
從以前古典學派
一路到各類似的畫風
陸續出爐
它的目的就是
因為它已經可以記錄真實畫面了
那我要怎麼樣構建我的世界觀呢
從印象派開始畫光線
感受
立體派
拆解觀看的方式
抽象藝術
乾脆離開具體的物件
所以相機它並沒有終結藝術
它是把藝術從複製世界
變成重新理解世界
今天的深層式AI
也是帶來同樣的變化
當我們寫出一篇通順的文章
做出一張漂亮的照片
很便宜
但人類的價值生產內容
才是決定你值得什麼被表達
我覺得這本書非常非常的有意思
它真的可以讓你
對於AI的世界
瞭解得更為透徹
AI會取代很多事情
但是唯一取代不了的
是你對於這個世界的好奇心
而且08分
我們一樣抽出兩本書
送給我們的投資朋友
歡迎大家把這本書買回家
送到的書
那就再送給你喜愛的人
給投資朋友做些參考
大家如果有興趣
可以在我們頻道底下留言
留下你對於本書
或者本節目的一些看法
我們禮拜一抽兩本書
送給我們的投資朋友
好 臺股小跌200點
本週其實波動並不是特別大
一樣跟美國股市
感覺都遇到了一股結界
不過你說美債這件事情有多恐慌
市場上反應也不是特別明顯
更類似於勒索式
勤勒式寬鬆
要求你付出更多的金融流動性
這也給投資朋友做一些思考
如果喜歡我們的節目
就幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就禮拜一早上八點半
早晨財經世界圖再相見
祝各位投資朋友開門順利
操盤愉快